[Music]
and we do have garry kasparov on the
line with us
welcome to the show Gary thank you
so tell us a little bit about what you
think of the thing feel cut so far I
think it's very exciting event and yeah
I'm appalled to hear comments that the
event is another symbol of the end of
classical chairs look where's all the
knowledge of the internet blitz moving
to one zero or 30 seconds games and it's
so important for us to keep you know the
high standards and while that many
drones butt-fuck in in soccer we also
have games ending in a zero zero one
zero just you know it's these could be
scoreless drawers but it's it's high
quality and a lot of you know lot of fun
excitement because you can you can
hardly blame an opponent for the lack of
fighting spirit I'm truly impressed I
think it's great tools what if what if
your most memorable moments from the
tournament base so far what do you think
some of the highlights have been look
that many games as they look what I just
you know what makes me feel a bit say is
that you know it's vicious performance
you know it's as I say it's playing
Robin Hood you know he just gives up
every day and it's just it's it's it's
it's always painful to watch him into
building the strong position
you know pink some games by force and
then then the edge tells you know then
just you know it's vastly here to
actually look for in a for you know not
the force - to teach is defined but it
was who is Gary I mean it just it's why
to go for this pointy 537 I mean that's
for God's sake so this and of course was
dink I could even feel that wish it I
saw the amazing tag I said okay maybe I
should take it exchange and you know win
and just it's I can sense hesitations
and every game is better I mean today
he's it might be might be struggling but
it's just every game before it was
between winning or better so it's if you
by the number of missed opportunities
this could be the winner of the tour
but otherwise you know it seems a pink
world well and then he was like he was
vision that painting played by far the
best game in the tournament against
giving I think it was it was a position
of masterpiece it's really great yeah I
agree that was a fantastic victory and
how would you account for Gary first of
all hi how was the character for Magnus
Magnus is trying and he's getting
frustrated as well yeah but that's okay
you made the point he's getting
frustrated when you're getting
frustrated it doesn't help no yeah it's
you know who's - we know we just he
needs one win you know just and then
he's a stoppable did something just
didn't work out here and I was just
surprised and it all shocked that yes
yesterday against level she didn't even
consider the idea of you know of nice
fabulous exchange in Queensland and he
after long thought he'd be made very
just in a pod move nursing a 95 giving
up 5 points that tells you that
something is something is just pretty
playing his mind I mean is it's still
the best player yes there's no doubt
about it but it's not enough to be
player to win every game and then it
seems that is is he struggling and one
hand is it's a pity that he doesn't show
his two strengths on the other hand it
makes the event Maurice when he talked
about that line that you mentioned with
Bishop Basics in 93 he said that it was
the spirit of Benko in a moment and of
course unfortunately a sad day for chess
yesterday as pals in house and did you
have any great memories of him Gary
I met him occasionally but I think
that's one of the one of the creative
minds I guess it shows you know not from
is from Banker Gundaker idea that you
know survive generations and generations
and still is very much
playable but also I mean the way he
composed this phenomenal status it's it
shows that these age you know he hasn't
lost this these through the creativity
its young chess chat the big ones yeah
indeed he was composing into his 90s as
he didn't tacit the age of 91 what do
you think about the games today Gary is
there anything that I know it's very
early in the round but you have any bold
predictions look I mean it's early in
the round better justice busy I when I
switched answer I think you guys
discussed mvl game and I am you know and
it's it's a memory of so I you know my
early days because I analyzed this line
extensively first was white there will
be a bit core infrastructure in 20 in
less than 25 moves so it's a very
dangerous line very betrays me but I
think it was it was told he would
probably yes so what I remember you know
it's that state in this position so you
should need a play after be some e6000
f6 I remember was not a good rule 55
that's that's what I remember again I
never changes in computer should be 7 or
e6 this would be some or pony six that's
what that one hour
I drew the remember I remember that you
know after each six Castle be should be
seven black holes and after Bishop this
yes castle
we should be seven black holes narrowly
but also it just it's that's that's my
analysis because since I shifted to
grifoll in late nineteen so analyzed was
black as well so and
after Bishop d7 one of the key lines was
visual text e6 Bishop takes to 695 King
he ate and now knight c6 b c6 again if
memory serves well black holes narrowly
I think after King etudes probably 85
and then he better sacrifice pollinate a
seven and bring rook on d6 and again
it's black hole now but it's it's very
I'm sure machine could probably tell us
otherwise but that's what I can share
with you but f65 is always very good
rooms you can check was it wasn't f6 a
teaming play yes tom
sorry Gary your memory is better than
mine and Mahal line with f6 really makes
a very strange impression to me and
we're absolutely convinced that the
movie 6 and what mvl is done is dead I
mean yes to give up a change now but
it's absolutely yeah but I don't know it
just it said it did not happen however
he did not accept the exchange you just
played castles what did what has
happened as castled after an f6 Bishop
c4 e6 he didn't gasp castles long or
short it's still probably very strong
you know prayer I also every else is a
short type of player who's very good
choice it's this line is it's almost
forgotten and it puts back you know some
for time you know it's two blacks on the
ropes and and I think every house is in
terrible shape now so and I think never
made a very good choice so also he has
yes concept wind in his sails deciced
so Gary you're coming into town to play
960 let us know
how do you feel about that you're
playing against Fabiano marijuana okay
you know I'm very excited so I always
know we're excited to come and play
chess and there and with 960 again I
don't have to I don't know if I talk to
my memory you know if you're retiring
and you're coming back to enjoy play you
you you took on maybe the biggest
challenge you could with the exception
of Magnus Carlsen you pick on number two
in the world it's not classical chance
it's not real chances 960 and oh god you
know dates it's fun so why you'd want to
have some fun yeah a lot of funds Fabi
it's just he definitely don't just do
this he doesn't play his best tournament
yeah so yesterday he suffered very
painful defeats but again so we made one
sleep at that just so no no way back how
do you prepare for a 960 tournament oh I
just play a lot of games with internet
so sometimes it's it's very frustrating
because you know it's it's very
difficult to actually verify that you
player in opponent actually I have to
say I just I watched was a qualifier
form for feeding wall jumpers exactly on
the chest comm network yeah cousins comp
a couple of days ago right Sergei were
playing the finals and we shoot blanks
with yeah it's scandalous because you
know you saw what happened you know is
this unknown player for nobody nowhere
who just you know made to the
semi-finals and the way trash behave and
then Vanya and then play on par with
Bruce you can play was 2400
I think it's just you know the guys from
Chester
to do a better job I mean this is new I
only would have to look at the game by
the way I did just to tell you that the
game was not surprised
it's it's we know it happens on the
internet but it's a so-called qualifier
it's a world championship bet and I feel
sorry for such aggression
I mean heat Sasha always Saturday now
just bluntly honest boss more and press
conference that Ziegler played well in
the final but Sasha after playing in
seven games against is no entity from
one I mean just he felt exhausted and
also frustrated I can imagine you know I
think he was holding his time two curts
on camera it doesn't happen yes
unfortunately we did not follow that
story Gary but we would like to give a
big shout out to Peters Hitler to see
player suffering you know and
recognizing that view or just all of a
sudden you know the force against you
and it's bad news wanna point out just
before we let you go you remember he was
correct f6 was played in tal vs. 2 min
so okay good night it was it was a 1985
they played you see the ladies extra
qualifier yes to play in the candidates
am I correct and then they played is the
extra match and I think three three
years and team qualifies because I think
tomorrow's Gary your memories so good
you got the year right you got
everything set do you remember the day
it happened a month look you know I
because probably one of the reasons I
remember the match because it still what
is wine I think that no no just think I
I'm always comment Olli interviews this
line and and young couldn't find I don't
know defense and crusty very nicely by
the way I was playing on November 6 just
and and Michael tall qualified for
Montpelier how do I know that because I
played in Montpelier you play but it
kind and they there's a one [ __ ] and
people eventually they had to play one
spot for candidates what are the rooms
but somehow they have to play this
qualifier I remember because you were
playing World Championship match with
yeah Gary thank you for joining us we're
gonna see you at ultimate moves yeah all
right will reply back to New York and
force-wide Sunday morning from New York
to San Luis wonderful thank you thank
you so much for joining us Gary Kasparov
you here to here first not only is it
gonna be playing in the 960 but it also
be here a couple days early to play in
ultimate moves which is gonna take place
on Thursday August 29th
that's always the fun exhibition matches
where X takes on his son Randy with the
team of all-stars backing them up oh
yeah that's always a lot of fun so with
especially Gary Gary really makes that
of it well it's not that they're not
taking it seriously they want to win but
Gary Gary makes them take it serious
everybody's trash saw that when Gary
sits everybody goes quiet
to upset the king let's get it done boys
so we don't want to lose this game I got
a very clear fine so Justin looking fool
so now no now after the Russian coming
through I remember I lost a wonderful
bet - Gary we were in Prague we all went
out to dinner together and somehow he
got on the subject of injures oh no I
played in and he said blah blah blah and
you played Yusupov from Park if' ski and
Spassky in your inner zonal and I go no
no I did use of pop wasn't in my inner
zone alone because yes he was and you
played this line and he played that line
and you played this and he played that
no no no that wasn't the inner zone oh
that was this other tournament I played
with abusive father he said no and of
course we made a bet and of course
somebody had a their computer and of
course Gary was right against Gary
unless you're Magnus exactly and Gary
said to me there's only one guy he ever
lost to in memory yeah and that was uri
bala Shaw is an aspartic he had and on a
bus and then we're all talking about
this this variation and everybody was
shouting and Gary said and this happened
and this happened it was between these
two players and URI balashov says Gary
is connect and it was around nine
[Music]
every game of chess Magnus is supposed
to have a legendary memory as well right
I don't yeah that's very good memory but
today I mean if I remember ball balance
of correctly I mean it's nobody can
close everybody else people like me very
easy for guys all right you can see what
you really think
yeah
[Music]